ils étaient près de 900 parlementaires
réunis à versailles pour écouter le
président de la république fixer le cap
de son quinquennat
parmi eux 18 représenter le département
des yvelines pour les 12 députés
fraîchement élus lors des élections
législatives
ce congrès était une première marquée
par l'importance du moment et le poids
des responsabilités
une solennité particulière évidemment
d'être à versailles
l'ensemble de la représentation
nationale qui est ici donc c'est
évidemment particulier
cet engagement que le président avait
pris et qu'il met en place aujourd'hui
devenir une fois par an devant
l'ensemble des parlementaires non
seulement dit que miner la vision et le
cap pour l'année à venir mais également
faire l'évaluation de son analyse de
l'analyse politique il a proposé et des
lois qui ont été mis en place et tu est
une excellente idée si la forme a
conquis les nouveaux députés de la
république en marche le fond lui a
divisé les parlementaires des
parlementaires visés directement par
quelques unes des propositions des
manuels macron avec par exemple la
réduction de leur nombre d'un tiers ou
encore l'instauration d'une dose de
proportionnelle pour les prochaines
élections législatives
la difficulté constitutionnel qu'il ya
dans le bel la baisse du nombre de
sénateurs ou députés
c'est la bonne représentation est le
fait des territoires ruraux des
territoires bien moins de monde et le
fait que le député puisse faire son
travail dans des temps qu'ils soient
raisonnables restant bien le l'image de
la diversité de nos territoires donc ça
c'est la première éléments la
proportionnelle je suis pas une fan du
tout parce qu'on a souvent des effets
d'appareils le paquet de réformes
institutionnelles sera voté d'ici un an
selon le souhait du président de la
république et devrait donc être actées
lors du congrès épisode 2 prévue l'an
prochain nous en nourrir